قال منسق السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي ان روسيا تحاول انتاج صراع اشمل
واوسع مع الاتحاد الاوروبي من خلال الحرب
الاوكرانيه مضيفا ان الاتحاد لم يكن
مستعدا بالشكل الكافي عند بدء المعركه
روسيا تحاول تحويل المعركه مع اوكرانيا
الى حرب اشمل مع الغرب وعلى الدول
الاوروبيه تقاسم الاعباء الدفاعيه والدفاع
عن قيام ومبادئ الامم المتحده كما يجب
تطوير دور التكتل الدفاعي والسيبراني خلال
الفتره المقبله الى جانب التركيز على
تقديم المزيد من الذخائر لاوكرانيا
وشدد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بورن على ضروره تطوير دور
التكتل الدفاعي والسبراني وخلال كلمه كلمه
له في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن اكد بولد ضروره
زياده وتشريع المساعدات العسكريه
الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا
واضاف المسؤول الاوروبي انه يجب على دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان ترسل ما لديها من
الذخيره ولا تنتظر كي تشتري يدخائره جديده
لترسلها
وقال انه على المدى المتوسط يجب زياده
قدره الانتاج الدفاعي الاوروبي شريطه ان
تكون هناك ذخائر كافيه لكافه الدول على حد
تعبيرها
الى ميونخ حيث مراسله العربيه راغده بهنام
تتابع هذا المؤتمر رغد اهلا وسهلا بك
مجددا اخر ما خرج به مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
وهذا التصعيد سيد الموقف تماما راغده من
دون الحديث عن اي حل سياسي للحرب في
اوكرانيا
اهلا بك طالب يعني انتهى هذا المؤتمر قبل
قرابه الساعه من الان وغادر معظم المشركين
ولكن بالفعل الاستنتاج الطاغي هنا على انه
عوضا عن حل ربما مساله واحده ظهرت مشاكل
اخرى اضافيه الان على المجتمع الغربي ان
يواجهها على راسها يعني الازمه بين الصين
والغرب وتحديدا بين بكين واشنطن كان هناك
امل بان يكون لقاء وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
مع المسؤول الصيني هنا يعني ياتي او يؤدي
الى تخفيف هذا التوتر ولكن على ما يبدو
هذا اللقاء لم يخفف هذا التوتر بل على
العكس ربما زاده لانه سمعنا من بلينك
اليوم يقول يعني في مقابله ادلى بها لاحدى
وسالام الامريكيه بانه حذر بانه هناك
اشارات ان الصين ربما تستعد لمساعدات
عسكريه لاعطاء مساعدات عسكريه لروسيا وقال
بانه ابلغ المسؤول الصيني بانه هذا الامر
سيؤثر بشكل كبير سلبي على العلاقات
الثنائيه بين الصين المتحده ايضا يعني
هناك مصدر قلق اضافي للدول الغربيه فهمتي
من دبلوماسي غربي بانه العلاقه العسكريه
بين ايران وروسيا وهي علاقه متزايده بحسب
مقاله ايضا باتت الان تشكل مصدر قلق رئيسي
لهذه الدول الغربيه التي الان تسعى لدفع
ايران يعني لفك هذه العلاقه العسكريه مع
روسيا لذلك بالفعل ربما يمكن القول بانه
هذه الازمه الحرب على اوكرانيا
ومتفرعاتها كانت هي يعني ما طغى على هذا
المؤتمر ولم يكن هناك اي يعني ربما حلول
طرحت ولكن مخاوف جديده تحدث عنها
الزعمائنا وسمعنا من جوالي اليوم كلام
يعني صادقه جدا بانه اذا لم نسرع بارسال
الذخيره لاوكرانيا خلال الاسابيع المقبله
ونتوقف عن التباطؤ يعني ربما يعني نواجه
نهايه للحرب وفوز يعني ولم يقلها بهذا
المعنى ولكن قال بانه يجب ان لا نتباطى
اكثر وجها انتقادات لاذعه للدول الاوروبيه
لانها قالت من خلال متابعتك للمواقف هل تم
التوافق اوروبي امريكي واضح من ان هذه
الحرب يجب ان تستمر اي ان تكن التكلفه ام
لا بعض الدول الاوروبيه تخشى التداعيات
الكلام ليس على استمرار الحرب ولكن الكلام
من جميع القاده الغربيين على ضروره الا
تفوز لا يفوز الرئيس بوتن بحربه يعني هم
يصرون ايضا على تكرار بانه هذه حرب فوت
توتن
ويقولون بان هذا ضمن طموحاته ما يسمونه
طموحات الامبرياليه لذلك يعني هناك اسرار
على استمرار هذا الدعم لكي لا تفوز روسيا
بهذه الحرب ولكي يعني تحقق اوكرانيا بعد
الانتصارات على الاقل لكي تتمكن من الجلوس
على طاوله الحوار بشروط يعني لا تكون فقط
شروط روسيا هذا ما تحدث به الرئيس الفرنسي
اليوم الاول للمؤتمر في الواقع ولكن اليوم
يعني كان ايضا كلام من رئيسه حكومه
استونيا هنا التي جلست معجزه بارال في
طاوله الحوار وتقول بانه علينا الاستعداد
لما بعد نهايه هذه الحرب وليس يعني علينا
الاستعداد بمعنى عسكريا كدول اوروبيه لانه
هذه يعني
حتى ولو انتهت الحرب في اوكرانيا فالمخاطر
علينا باقيه ومستمره في السنوات القادمه
قيل وشاهدنا بعض الصور عن احتجاجات شعبيه
في عدد من المدن الالمانيه تطالب
المجتمعين في مؤتمر ميونخ بعدم ارسال اي
اسلحه جديده الى اوكرانيا الى ماذا يعني
هذه التظاهرات كانت كبيره حجم هذه
التظاهرات
يعني هذه التظاهرات تخرج في كل مؤتمر دولي
يعني هي خرجت في قمه السبع التي استضافتها
المانيا قبل يعني العام الماضي وايضا قبل
بضعه سنوات هي ترافق هذه يعني الاجتماعات
بشكل دائم ولكن المستشار الالماني الذي
ايضا تحدثي اليوم الاول هو كان يشرح ما
يرى بانه تردد المانيا ولكنه كان يقول نحن
يجب علينا ان نمشي بحسب يعني الاراده ربما
الشعبيه كان يلمح الى انه يعني الشعب الذي
انتخب هذه الحكومه هو يثق بها قال بانه
استطلاعات الراي تؤكد بانه الشعب مازال
يثق بنا وهو لا يرى ترددنا هذا تردد بل
يرى بانه اصرار على انه لا نذهب وحيدين لا
نكون الوحيدين الذين نتصرف بشكل احادي
بارسال هذه الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا لذلك
هناك ثقه لدى الحكومه على الاقل بانه
الشعب الالماني خلفها في ارسال هذه
الاسلحه
العربيه راغده بهنام شكرا جزيلا لك راغده
على كل هذه المتابعه